this is a good idea so I used to buy
this gum from the grocery store and it
was just like regular Wrigley's extra or
whatever but it was my study gum so I
only studied it when I chewed it and I
only chewed it when I was about to study
it was like my sacred study gum but
there's nothing special about the gum
whatsoever again like I said it was just
like Wrigley's extra bubble mint flavor
not a word of a lie
it made me study a lot better and I
think it has something to do with the
placebo effect
so the placebo effect which you've
probably heard of before is basically a
beneficial effect caused by an
ineffective treatment since the
beneficial effect can't be attributed to
the treatment itself and therefore has
to be attributed to the patient's belief
in the treatment this is a very real
phenomenon
and one of the biggest mysteries in the
realm of psychology literal sugar pills
have cured cancer staved off depression
the list goes on and like I said it has
nothing to do with the drug and
everything to do with the patient
thinking that the drug is gonna work
according to the American Cancer Society
the person taking the placebo may
experience something along the lines of
what he or she expects to happen if
person expects to feel better that may
happen if the person believes that he or
she is getting a strong medicine the
placebo may be thought to cause the
side-effects the placebo does not cause
any of these effects directly instead
the person's belief in or experience of
the placebo helps change the symptoms or
changes the way the person perceives the
symptoms so whether you're sick with an
illness or just need to get work done we
can learn a lot from the placebo effect
and perhaps use it to our advantage so
whenever you hear me talk about on this
channel the sacred playlist sacred space
or in this case the sacred gum it's kind
of whoo-whoo crap but it works your
belief that these things will work
actually means something is tangible it
will produce results and since you know
that some of these things that I say
don't really literally work well that
cause them to the end of
again that totally depends on your
attitude because when I bought that gum
from the store do you think I didn't
know that it was just regular flavored
Wrigley's extra bubble made gum like I'm
not an idiot I know that's just regular
gum but I wanted it to help me study I
wanted something official to just sort
of kick off my study sessions it was my
productivity go it worked because I
believed it did same thing with my
productivity playlist when I press play
on that baby
there's not a chance I'm gonna get
distracted because that thing is sacred
once I press play there's no screwing
around it's go time
so if you're in desperate need for a
productivity boost consider finding your
own productivity placebo because it
doesn't actually have to work you just
have to believe it does if you like this
video and like videos like these then I
want to hear from you like the comment
subscribe to the channel like the
comment what though like the video
comment I want to hear from you and best
of all subscribe to the channel because
there's a lot more advice to come
whether it works or not
my videos just became so much shadier
thank you all of it is old